[Music]
in post-sex blues news oh oh that's
tragic submitted by JK news is the
realest oh yeah thanks guys so stupid
real I'm getting checked left and right
right now 41 seconds
a new study discusses how and why some
men feel sad after sex I could name one
I heard this is pretty common but if
they're religious they feel guilty and
then they get sad I used to feel guilt
after I jacked off really yeah I've been
growing up like sex was so taboo yeah
yeah yeah yeah my parents are turn-off
like love scenes so when I first started
my career of Jack and I would just
always feel so sad afterwards but then
you can't stop doing it do you remember
when you discovered jacking off you're
like whoa this is something you know
when I first started jacking off the
first time ever I actually dry-humped
myself so I remember my underwear and
all that just feels good and I just kept
petting it and it started like I was
more rigorous about it and then pretty
soon I was like oh there's a different
feeling there's a different feeling and
I busted inside my underwear oh what the
[ __ ]
and I'm like well ash it was crazy
you DJed your dick yeah over underwear
it wasn't even skin on skin contact
yeah maybe like 11 12 you're like that's
how man created fire accidentally
simulating jacking off easy they start
sharing with the other guys you see two
things can happen
you tell top dated you don't make you
fire yeah researchers from the
Queensland University of Technology did
this study on post-coital dysphoria or
its coital sounds so wack yeah sounds
like a [ __ ] weird thing PCD I like
that so this results in feelings of
sadness cheerfulness or irritability
after sex
irritability after sex what it's weird
this condition has been recognized in
women but this is the first time ever
that they've recognized this in men or
maybe it's been happening but guys never
talked about it yeah so what they did is
that they're sleeping probably yeah cuz
what do you call it that boys no boys
post nut we post close drama post come
coma
yeah post come comas they had this
international anonymous online survey of
1208 men from Australia US UK Russia New
Zealand do you get fired after sex is
that that survey me I don't know what
they read exactly but the results are
that 41% of the participants reported
experiencing PCD in their lifetime and
20% reported that they had experienced
it in the previous four weeks and up to
4% suffer from it on a regular basis you
know what I just remember I was such a
bro right after high school that I used
to have post jackoff protein shakes
I would jack off but I felt like I was
like oh [ __ ] I'm losing nutrients I'm
gonna get smaller and I would pound of
produce again that was my friend's dad
dude every time he [ __ ] boned his
girl I just remembered right he will
come out and he would have a protein
shake and he would do the same [ __ ] yeah
I just remember
just finished chatting no no he he
[ __ ] his girlfriend because you know I
like that that Chinese horoscope should
they believe that when you [ __ ] the
woman do some cheers my boxers don't
[ __ ] before yeah yeah I supposed to have
sex while you're trained for a boxing
match yeah but for some reason he
thought a protein shake would replenish
his energy yeah but yeah I was like that
was the oddest thing no I love that the
kids are in the living room when he's
banging his girlfriend in the other room
yeah guys just take care of yourself
play a little tari why go light up to
where his priorities lie mental health
but if I'm gonna take this protein shake
for my cheese yeah we were like 16 I
think we're all of your like [ __ ]
like five or six years but they were
banging and then he's like sweating and
[ __ ] drinking this protein shake that
one huh you hear how daddy smash the
[ __ ] yeah tell us after we do it we
need to we need to charge back up and
we're like all right that's weird I
believe in science how I mean creaming
dirty I think once you bust a knot
you're just a million emotions go
through you yes you're like uh how long
you guys stay here or she's not back all
right what the [ __ ] did I just do yes
the theme song for that that clarity you
speak of do you care to share what goes
into my head like I feel like for that
ten seconds of bliss right when you nut
I think that's how clear your mind
should be when you're like enlightened
cuz you're not thinking about anything
else
you're comforting enlightenment and
Nutting yeah is yeah I think you get a
peek at enlightenment yep cuz you don't
want that feeling of the [ __ ] that's the
10 15 seconds where a man doesn't even
care about how much [ __ ] or titty or
anything and it's just I need to be a
better person by giving more like it's
like some [ __ ] like that and I forgot to
do the laundry it's not somebody 10
seconds where you bust and if you look
out the window and someone jacked your
Amazon package you don't even care
yeah just take it you just start
thinking spiritual quotes at that point
you're
an Instagram model takes pictures of her
butthole and put five reports under it
that one moment any guy that loses their
keys just jack off 15 seconds you'll
remember it right there that'd be a
great cop show just like you can't solve
the mystery so you just feed off Bob did
it in the living room yeah all the
detectors just jacking off yeah who
killed us hold on a second you know help
from guilt right so have you guys ever
felt like any sort of PCD pretend we're
anonymous right now right there's no
judgment in this room we won't call you
[ __ ] I feel like what what what I did
feel was regret because when you think
clear sometimes you go oh my god I
[ __ ] her and in 10 seconds come back
yeah
the younger you are I think you
recharged better and then you go 30
minutes I can [ __ ] again yeah but in
that 10 minutes are like oh my god like
she should have Strangler along maybe
she thinks we want a relationship I
don't know this is so [ __ ] up man what
am i 15 seconds pass want to try again
yeah because they're saying here that
some of these participants they
described experiences ranging from I
don't want to be touched and I want to
be left alone to feeling unsatisfied
annoyed and very fidgety all I really
want is to leave and distract myself
from everything I participated in and
another feeling is emotionless and empty
and then there's other men who
experience post-coital experience
positively where it's like feelings of
well-being satisfaction contentment
closeness to their partners I'm that bad
sighs it's like good [ __ ] versus a
bad [ __ ] that's all it really sounds
like yeah love sex and sport [ __ ]
yeah single guys just [ __ ] everything
that walks and then you'll guilty of
hurt yeah there was no other single
women that just sticks on a stick
yeah nobody talks about that dude yeah
women that use men
well girls get laid a lot more than they
let on because they don't want you to
think that they're you know that they
fool around but they get laid a lot more
like I always know guys who want to have
open relationships with their
girlfriends like dude girls get slim
dick at them constantly they're like
they're just dick goalies concept like
my buddy was like him his girlfriend
we're like all we're gonna have open
relationship she [ __ ] half the
neighborhood dude he liked that - chick
she banged everybody on the neighborhood
I had a friend of mine we were talking
the other day she's like how many guys
you've been with I mean how many guys
appear how many girls have been with and
I was like I stopped counting in the 90s
you know yeah I just stopped I got to a
certain number yeah it's like was a lot
I go you know you don't want to answer
that question yeah cuz the girl watch
you have experience but not too much
experience so we were just sitting there
and she goes you know sometimes I'll
[ __ ] like three guys in a day I go
sometime that means multiple times
because it's like it's they like sex -
obviously I feel like I could have done
that when I was 14 so what's your point
that we're not admitting to the number
yeah like oh like guys are dogs right
but women participate in as much um yeah
but I think the percentage is for sure
is more like I did you know more than
you think well because of the judgement
that like so four guys it could be dogs
all you want you get rooted for it but
then once a girl admit then she's a [ __ ]
well there there's some biology behind
that because it basically comes down
that nobody wants to raise another
person's kid so the only way you could
really tell your kid is lock that snatch
down you know put in a [ __ ] dick
prison so it can't go anywhere and
that's why you make sure it's your kid
you know and a dick prison and here's
the weirdest thing rich people like when
you get to that super elite level they
all just [ __ ] each other
mm-hmm and that's why you look you're
like I don't think that's his kid and
you look it looks like someone who's a
friend of theirs you know just get bored
they just bone each other like this
bodyguard oh yeah
[ __ ] kid a hundred percent good luck
that's his little ching chong kid that
is his I've never seen a more Asian
child in my life you might as well have
a [ __ ] rice hat on that child could
there be any worse role model for women
than the Kardashians they can't [ __ ]
more unstable in your life [ __ ] like
my space rappers [ __ ] bat down
oh my god yeah that is so crazy that's
the role model of today for women I mean
they're witches dude and I'm not even
joking like they are into Dark Arts [ __ ]
when you look at like they suck the bone
marrow spirit not every guy they [ __ ]
hook up with they all crash and burn but
they all want that heat man you get into
that light that promotion but they just
eat you up man they spit you out
they're like the Black Widow they really
are man they're like praying mantis you
know they eat their mate after he lays
the seeds on the eggs they walk around
Mandy's like there's just things from
the occult that you see like certain
ways you dress certain colors they they
do all giving them way too much credit
no dude I'm telling you they'll
calculate I'm being dead serious they
are straight-up witches you don't know
magic
dude you don't know like when you get to
that level I want to get to that level
and [ __ ] tell the world
that's not you're never gonna get to
that level you might get to down that
ball and they might have cast a spell on
you and you can anymore
nope it doesn't work on Asians we're
even more mystical [ __ ] that we got that
ancient blood I know how to meditate
[Music]